[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis guten abend und herzlich
willkommen alles zur deutschen medaille
heute bei den paralympics erfahren sie
von norbert leben ein stück von mir und
wir schauen in dieser sendung
ausführlich nach afghanistan unsere
großen themen
explosion am flughafen kabul tage lang
wurde vor der terrorgefahr gewarnt heute
dann zwei anschläge mit vielen toten und
verletzten
flucht über den ärmelkanal eine asyl
reform soll flüchtlinge abschrecken doch
immer mehr wagen die gefährliche
überfahrt nach großbritannien
und jubel bei den paralympics verena
schott holt über 200 meter lagen bronze
und damit die zweite medaille für
deutschland
während die letzten evakuierungsflüge
vom flughafen kabul staaten hat es dort
zwei anschläge gegeben die rede ist von
mehr als zehn toten und vielen
verletzten das genaue ausmaß ist im
moment noch nicht abzusehen
wir schauen jetzt ausführlich nach
afghanistan blicken auf dem bundeswehr
einsatz beginnen aber mit den
dramatischen szenen nach den explosionen
am flughafen glück weil dort
ein erster sprengsatz explodierte
unmittelbar neben einem von us soldaten
bewachten tor kurz danach eine weitere
explosion an einem hotel in
flughafennähe das als sammelpunkt für
ausreichende diente mindestens zwölf
menschen kamen ums leben krankenhäuser
berichten von dutzenden verletzten
die explosion war da im wassergraben in
dem die leute standen
wir sind sofort aus dem graben raus aber
da lagen ganz viele menschen blut ich
auf dem boden zum teil auch zerfetzte
körper alle haben geschrien das war eine
sehr heftige explosion auch ausländische
soldaten waren betroffen
nach amerikanischen medienberichten sind
terroristen einer splittergruppe des des
sogenannten islamischen staates für die
anschläge verantwortlich geheimdienste
hatten in den letzten tagen wiederholt
vor einem hohen risiko gewarnt der
sprecher des amerikanischen
verteidigungsministeriums bestätigte
dass auch us-soldaten bei den anschlägen
verletzt wurden bundeswehr-soldaten so
hieß es in berlin seien nicht betroffen
den ganzen tag über starteten weiter
maschinen aus kabul es sind wohl mit die
letzten zivilisten die heute noch über
die militärische luftbrücke die ausreise
geschafft haben zahlreiche staaten wie
kanada belgien und ungarn haben die
evakuierungsflüge inzwischen eingestellt
die amerikaner und ihre verbündeten
haben bereits mit dem abtransport von
mannschaften und material begonnen der
bis zum nächsten dienstag abgeschlossen
sein soll schutzbedürftige könnten dann
mit zivilen flugzeugen ausgeflogen
werden heißt es ein zeitpunkt ab wann
das möglich sein wird ist nicht bekannt
zugeschaltet sind mir jetzt katrin
eigendorf aus taschkent und mrt wissen
aus den usa zuerst zu ihnen immer die
usa haben ja vor anschlägen gewarnt was
ist denn bisher bekannt über die
möglichen hintergrund der explosion
das weiße haus und das pentagon ging
davon aus dass es sich mit höchster
wahrscheinlichkeit um einen
doppelanschlag vom es in afghanistan
handelt einem ableger des islamischen
staates die kämpfer sind in der lage
koordinative koordinierten attacken
auszuüben darum handelt es sich hier
ganz offenbar das hotel das berlin hotel
liegt wenige hundert meter von diesem
erbe gate am flughafen entfernt das ist
der ort das hotel wo normalerweise sich
die menschen sammelt evakuiert werden
sollen darüber geführt werden teilweise
der weg ist sehr schmal es gibt einen
abwasserkanal und eine mauer die dann
die wirkung einer solchen attacke
tatsächlich verstärken würde und
insofern gehen die usa davon aus dass
das genau geplant war die große frage
ist wie sind die terroristen bis dorthin
gekommen denn es gibt mehrere
kontrollpunkte der taliban aber auch
natürlich die us-soldaten gleich in der
nähe die das gelände überwachen aber es
zeigt im grund haben wie verletzlich die
operation ist und was jetzt diskutiert
und beraten wird inwieweit die
evakuierung in den nächsten fünf tagen
noch weiter gehen kann gehen wir gleich
mal zu ihnen kathrin sie sind in
taschkent am drehkreuz der deutschen
truppen was bedeutet das jetzt für den
einsatz und den abzug der bundeswehr
ja wir haben leider keine informationen
ob die flieger die heute über taschkent
gehen sollten nun wirklich abheben
konnten und hier heute noch landen
können das haben wir nicht in erfahrung
bringen können wurde uns nicht bestätigt
aber es bedeutet natürlich dass dieser
einsatz in frage steht was man
sicherlich davon ausgehen muss dass die
leute die jetzt noch in der
warteschlange draußen stehen wohl es
kaum noch schaffen werden man muss davon
ausgehen dass sicherlich die leute die
jetzt im flughafen also in den
militärischen teil des kabuler
flughafens sind die wird man noch
irgendwie außer landes bringen aber
jetzt überlegt man ja schon optionen in
den verhandlungen mit den taliban zu
erreichen mit zivilen maschinen weiter
menschen aus dem land zu bringen aber
dazu muss man eben jetzt das okay der
taliban gekommen vielen dank für diese
einschätzung katrin eigendorf und mrt
wissen
seit zehn tagen ist die bundeswehr am
flughafen kabul im einsatz mit mehreren
transportmaschinen wurden tausende
menschen in sicherheit gebracht
laut
verteidigungsministerium konnten bislang
fast 5000 350 menschen ausgeflogen
werden darunter mehr als 4100
afghaninnen und afghanen sehen
ortskräfte und andere besonders
schutzbedürftige personen
außerdem waren mindestens 505 menschen
mit deutscher staatsangehörigkeit an
bord noch immer aber sind zahlreiche
ortskräfte in afghanistan wie können sie
jetzt noch das land verlassen mehrere
bundesländer fordern dazu vom bund ein
afghanistan gipfel es gibt weiter viel
kritik an der bundesregierung
das wichtigste sind die gespräche mit
den taliban dass die menschen sicher
ausfliegen können so bundesinnenminister
seehofer ines trams aus berlin
diese bilder gehören nun wohl bald der
vergangenheit an maschinen der
bundeswehr zur rettung von deutschen und
einheimischen mitarbeitern auch am
donnerstag hoben sie ab von kabul aus
mit dem ziel taschkent in usbekistan
doch es wird klar dass die phase 1 dh
die akute evakuierung sich schließen
wird und das ist umso wichtiger ist dass
wir ohne bruch in eine phase 2 gehen die
dann eher diplomatische natur sein wird
die akute evakuierung aus afghanistan
durch die deutschen und andere nationen
geht zu ende nun will die
bundesregierung den zu schützen denn
beistehen auf anderen wegen das land zu
verlassen
wir wissen dass das zeitfenster sich
schließt und es konnten zehntausende
menschen in sicherheit gebracht werden
aber ich will heute noch einmal
bekräftigen diejenigen die mit der
luftbrücke nicht mehr in sicherheit
gebracht werden können werden wir nicht
vergessen sondern wir werden uns weiter
um ihre ausreise bemühen die chance auf
eine militärmaschine zu kommen sie
schwindet immer mehr afghanen drängen
deswegen auf dem landweg in richtung
pakistan in doha katar verhandelt
derweil der deutsche entsandte marcus
bosse mit den taliban ziel freies geleit
für den landweg für diejenigen die raus
wollen und der weiterbetrieb des zivilen
teils des kabuler flughafens
ich will mich in der haut wenigen die
jetzt verhandelten stecken denn die
werden erpresst wir sind jetzt in der
schwachen position dadurch dass man
nicht rechtzeitig evakuiert hat haben
die taliban jetzt das heft des handelns
und werden die preise diktieren jeder
cent an geld beispielsweise was die
taliban geht ist aber eine stärkung des
internationalen terrorismus ihre für das
wochenende geplante reise nach israel
sagte kanzlerin merkel mit blick auf
afghanistan ab
und alabama die aus unserem
hauptstadtstudio
was kann die deutschen jetzt noch
bewegen so dass die verbliebenen
ortskräfte aus afghanistan heraus kommen
relativ schwer zu sagen es ist klar was
die bundesregierung noch bewegen will
annegret kramp karrenbauer steht jetzt
gerade noch vor den kameras mit einer
stellungnahme und sie hat gerade eben
noch einmal gesagt der dass sich die
bundesregierung denjenigen die jetzt
noch in kabul und in afghanistan sind
und schon zu sagen haben dass sie nach
deutschland reisen können weiterhin
verpflichtet fühlen und dass die
aufnahme zusage tatsächlich auch
weiterhin gilt sie hat aber auch
deutlich gesagt dass die luftbrücke von
deutscher seite aus jetzt erst einmal
beendet sei alle angehörigen des
auswärtigen amtes alle soldatinnen und
soldaten und angehörige der
bundespolizei die dort noch gewesen sind
in kabul um den einsatz zu koordinieren
seien jetzt ausgeflogen und jetzt müssen
eben andere mittel greifen dazu gehören
vor allem die verhandlungen mit den
taliban
antwort kramp karrenbauer sagte wir
verlassen uns auf die garantien die die
taliban geben aber wir haben es heute
gesehen die anschläge zeigen auch dass
die taliban möglicherweise nicht die
einzigen sind die in afghanistan über
das wohl und wehe der menschen dort
bestimmen sondern dass es immer noch
terrorgruppierungen gibt die dort
versuchen auch ihre möglichkeiten
deutlich zu machen und die schrecklichen
terror einsätze dort auch nutzen um
angst und schrecken und tod zu
verbreiten und damit stellt sich eben
die frage wie viel einfluss haben wir
überhaupt noch von außen hat die
bundesregierung überhaupt noch von außen
um ihre versprechen einzulösen
dankeschön chacon talabani und
gleich nach uns können sie ein zdf
spezial sehen zum terror am flughafen
und zur dramatischen lage in afghanistan
wir blicken auf die pandemie die
incidents hat ausgedient sagt der
bundesgesundheitsminister stattdessen
soll es ja vor allem darauf ankommen wie
viele menschen wegen cupid 19 stationär
im krankenhaus behandelt werden
steigende an einer region die zahlen
soll das betroffene bundesland über chor
ohne einschränkungen entscheiden so
spannt entwurf für die
koalitionsfraktion pablo sie dann über
die aktuellen corona zahlen
deutschland am beginn der vierten corona
welle die sieben tage incident steigt
weiter laut robert-koch-institut liegt
sie jetzt bei 66 vor einer woche
erreichte sie noch einen wert von 48 1
damit überschritt sie in den vergangenen
sieben tagen den richtwert von 50
neuinfektionen pro 100.000 einwohner bis
zu beginn der woche noch die wichtigste
messgröße in der korona pandemie
die regierung will diesen wert künftig
keine große bedeutung mehr beim essen
sondern vor allem auf die belegung der
krankenhausbetten setzen experten sehen
das kritisch
wir sollten diese intelligenz nicht
verteufeln weil dieses signal an die
bevölkerung
wir haben anderthalb jahre instanzen
geguckt ja und die sollen plötzlich
überhaupt keine rolle mehr spielen das
dass das stimmt nicht die instanzen und
intensiv belegungen sind linear
miteinander korreliert in den
krankenhäusern sind aktuell 3,7 prozent
der intensivbetten mit cupid patienten
belegt die große mehrheit der menschen
die in einer klinik landen ist nicht
kämpft wir haben wir haben jetzt
erstmals daten dazu wie viele patienten
mit coop 19 im krankenhaus ungeimpft
sind und haben gesehen dass wir alleine
letzte woche über 95 prozent der
patienten auf den intensivstationen
hatten die ungeimpft bahnen in der
gesamtbevölkerung liegt die zahl der
vollständig geimpften bei 59,7 prozent
die impfbereitschaft wächst allerdings
nur langsam
in den usa ist die korona krise mit
voller wucht zurück das land hat
weltweit wieder die höchsten neue
infektionszahlen rund
148.000 menschen haben sich innerhalb
eines tages angesteckt wurde zuletzt
gemeldet und viele davon erkranken
schwer mehr als 100.000 cupid
patientinnen müssen aktuell in
krankenhäusern behandelt werden dieses
schicksal trifft vor allem ungeimpfte
und damit immer mehr kinder und
jugendliche
claudia bates
auch die kogit stationen der
kinderkliniken sind jetzt voller als je
zuvor in der pandemie 1900 kinder am tag
müssen in krankenhäusern in den usa
durchschnittlich behandelt werden
viermal so viele wie noch vor zwei
monaten
sowie die zahlen insgesamt steigen im
ganzen land so werden wir auch bei
kindern ernstere fälle haben wir sehen
mehr kinder in krankenhäusern in den
intensivstationen und wir werden auch
todesfälle sehen
keine masken für unsere kinder auch die
jüngsten sind teil eines machtkampfes
republikanische gouverneure haben
verboten dass kinder in der schule
masken tragen einige schulbezirke wehren
sich dagegen bedrohungen sind die folge
nur drohungen und schikanen dass ich
mein gehalt verliere meinen job aber
letztlich muss sich unsere kinder
schützen auch wenn es mich den job
kostet
wenn schulbehörden gegen die anordnung
einer masken pflicht verhängen möchten
wird es auf elternabenden konfrontativ
eltern pro maske in grün die anderen in
blau die schüler sauer ihr trefft ihr
nicht die entscheidung er sagt uns nicht
was wir zu tun haben
doch vor allem da wo keine masken
getragen werden sind tausende schüler
und hunderte lehrer in quarantäne
ein normaler schulbetrieb nicht möglich
einer der wichtigsten wege ist die
kinder mit menschen zu umgeben die
geimpft sind und das sind lehrer und das
schulpersonal
längst wird der streit nicht nur auf der
straße sondern auch vor gerichten
ausgetragen während sich die
kinderstationen in den krankenhäusern
füllen
der britische regierung will das
asylrecht weiter verschärfen um härter
gegen geflüchtete vorzugehen die
beispielsweise von frankreich aus in
kleinbooten versuchen den ärmelkanal zu
überwinden um nach großbritannien zu
gelangen
am vergangenen samstag wurden dabei auf
see
828 geflüchtete aufgegriffen die route
ist gefährlich trotzdem wagen immer mehr
die überfahrt insgesamt erreicht in
diesem jahr bis jetzt über
12.500 menschen die englische küste mehr
als im gesamten vorjahr andreas stamm
berichtet
die britische küstenwache im
dauereinsatz bei ruhiger see stechen
täglich dutzende boote aus frankreich in
see 50 60 kilometer sind es bis zur
englischen küste für die die es aus
eigener kraft an land schaffen heißt es
warten auf die polizei
die wege auf denen die menschen vor
krone auf die insel gelangt sind nicht
mehr so durchlässig etwa über den
eurotunnel in lastwagen und so wird eine
neue route mehr genutzt was eine
sogwirkung auf andere hat die
rüberkommen dazu so der menschenrechtler
rechne man nun mit mehr afghanischen
flüchtlingen für die britische regierung
heikel die null illegale migration
versprochen hat im juli einen vertrag
mit frankreich schloss überfahrten
verhindern sollen nun 200 französische
grenze london überweist jährlich 4 60
millionen euro dazu sieht ein
gesetzentwurf vor wer künftig aus einem
sicheren land wie frankreich übersetzt
dem drohen bis zu vier jahre gefängnis
nicht genug auf einem rechtslastigen
tv-sender patroulliert nigel farage der
bekannteste drexhage befürworter macht
wieder stimmung mit dem thema migration
die regierung nur große versprechungen
aber es wird immer schlimmer ich schätze
dass wenn der trend so bleibt nichts
getan wird werden in diesem jahr 20
30.000 den ärmelkanal überquert
zurückschicken nach frankreich fordert
die rechte um verrat was ironischerweise
vor dem break sie zumindest möglich
gewesen wäre so stapeln sich in dover
die schlauchboote mit jedem neuen dürfte
sich die debatte über illegale migration
weiter verschärfen
die deutsche bahn will im tarifkonflikt
mit der gewerkschaft deutscher
lokomotivführer vorerst kein neues
angebot vorlegen sie forderte die gdl
jedoch auch wieder verhandlungen
aufzunehmen
die gdl fordere 3,2 prozent mehr lohn
und eine corona prämie die bahn bietet
3,2 prozent mehr lohn und eine corona
prämie so bahnchef lutz lediglich bei
der laufzeit legen beide seiten
auseinander
und für die etwa eine million
beschäftigten des öffentlichen dienstes
der länder liegt jetzt die forderung der
gewerkschaften auf dem tisch fünf
prozent mehr gehalt mindestens jedoch
150 euro monatlich verlangen verdi und
der beamtenbund dbb bei einer laufzeit
von zwölf monaten
die tarifverhandlungen sollen im oktober
beginnen
seit wochen wütenden kalifornien riesige
feuer nun bedroht ein weiterer brand
ortschaften im süden des
us-bundesstaates die behörden riefen
tausende anwohner des bezirk san
bernardino auf sich in sicherheit zu
bringen autos und häuser wurden bereits
ein raub der im gesamten land loader
nach offiziellen angaben 92 große
waldbrände die schon tausende
quadratkilometer wald zerstört haben und
nun kommen wir zu den paralympics in
tokio noch razzien und zur zweiten
medaille für das deutsche team
schwimmerin verena schott holte bronze
über 200 meter lagen und war
zwischenzeitlich im finale sogar auf
goldkurs am ende persönliche
bestleistung und ein platz auf dem
podest
als sie sich das teure schmuckstück aus
bronze um den hals hängt werden verena
schott die letzten meter des rennens
vermutlich noch einmal durch den kopf
gehen hinter der britin summers minuten
mit neuem weltrekord und der ukrainerin
mir recht ko schlägt sie als drittes
gibt auf jeden fall auftrieb für die
nächsten rennen und hoffnung
jetzt erst mal einen tag missen pause
das wahrscheinlich glücklichste deutsche
lächeln in tokio gehört heute verena
schott
die deutschen rollstuhl
basketballerinnen haben ein ehrgeiziges
ziel nämlich gold und haben ihre
ambitionen heute durch den haushohen
sieg in australien klar unterstrichen
die deutschen rollstuhl
basketballerinnen können feiern die
paralympics siegerinnen von london und
silbermedaillengewinnerin von rio
liefert ein absolut überzeugendes spiel
schon nach dem ersten viertel führte das
team von coach dennis 0 gegen australien
mit elf zählern und baute den vorsprung
bis zur pause auf 20 punkte aus
kapitänin müller lieferte 30 punkte und
so lief es auch in der zweiten hälfte
deutschland traf souverän gewann 77 zu
pascal ackermann hat die erste etappe
der deutschland tour gewonnen der
pfälzer setzte sich nach 191 4
kilometern von stralsund nach schwierig
im massensprint vor seinem landsmann
phil bauhaus und dem österreicher marco
haller durch ackermann der seinen
sechsten saisonsieg einfuhr übernahm
damit auch das rote trikot des
gesamtersten
bayern münchen ist souverän in die
zweite runde des dfb pokal eingezogen
durch ein ganzes dutzend treffern eric
choupo-moting war der mann des abends
der sturm ersatz für robert lewandowski
erzielte gegen den oberligisten bremer
sv vier tore am ende stand es 12 00 für
das team von fcb-trainer ja dass man das
nennt man wohl klaren sieg das war es
vom sport dankeschön aber das graue
wolken mit schauern und gewittern sind
morgen in der überzahl dazu bleibt es
kühl ob und wann es wieder wärmer wird
erfahren sie gleich von katja honnefer
um 21.55 begrüßt die claus kleber zum
heute journal und jetzt direkt nach
dieser sendung geht es weiter mit einem
zdf spezial zu den anschlägen am
flughafen in kabul und zur lage dort auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
das war ein klassischer kaltfront
durchgang den süddeutschland heute
erlebt hat sie sehen hier das wolkenband
und dieses blaue dass der regen die kalt
von karmann den alpen an und dahinter
lockerten die wolken auf es gab zum teil
kräftige schauer und gewitter aber
zwischendurch sahen sie auch mal die
sonne und mit kräftigen schauern geht es
jetzt auch in den abend und durch die
nacht weiter am ehesten trocken bleibt
die nacht zwischen dem sauerland und der
mosel und vielleicht auch im schwarzwald
der wind dazu kommt aus nordwestlichen
bis nördlichen richtungen und die
temperaturen sinken in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen auf 7 grad bis auf 8 grad
am alpenrand sonst werden es so 12 bis 9
grad und nur an der nordsee hier auf den
ostfriesischen inseln bleibt es bei 15
grad milder das ist milder als morgen
die höchsttemperaturen hier in den
östlichen mittelgebirgen liegen da sind
dass nämlich nur 13 grad sonst werden 15
bis 19 und am oberrhein vielleicht auch
mal 20 grad erreicht und morgen geht er
noch mehr regen schauer und kurze
gewitter als heute die sonne tut sich da
wirklich schwer und am freundlichsten
wird wohl noch hier am oberrhein wo es
ja auch am wärmsten wird und in den
nächsten tagen geht es sehr wechselhaft
weiter aber in der neuen woche wird es
dann vielleicht ein kleines bisschen
wärmer guten abend